welcome back to the show we are going to
go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 after a brief reset of the entire
thing let me go to my friend Pedro from
the 806 area code pero como esta su
Amiga hola mr. Baughman your toy bien
you know give you muy bien with you're
needed on the Shama soy oh I'm calling
from Texas you know you know Pedro I
know what's going on with you you were
pretending to be Colombian but you speak
with a not Colombian accent in Spanish
it's so unusual that's why I wanted to
call you today you know yeah I have well
I wanted to either talk about you know I
had a question for you or I had some
evidence that I'm from Colombia you know
yeah I am why did you develop this
accent because no one in Colombia speaks
the way you speak Spanish oh you know
this is just how my family talks you
know we're from Colombia well you know I
grew up around some that they can do you
know they are going to Colombia
yeah would you be willing to share Pedro
of what you look like
you give me Ella yeah I can do but
anyways the evidence I had you know I
found my my birth certificate you know I
hold I'm actually holding it right now
you know yeah it says you know I'm from
Colombia and it has my name can you
actually read it for me for me just
start reading the birth certificate for
me oh you know it's kind of a boring
read you know but I would love it and
I'm sure it's in Spanish because your
Colombian right just start reading it it
must be right in front of you
okay you know I can try to leave it you
know please I didn't know if your
viewers wanted to like listen to me you
know read abortion if you trust me I can
also okay you know okay this is arrow
along yeah and then I have the data I
was born and then it has my long name
you're pretty good and then having my
god okay now honestly are you an
American guy well I am American now you
know but you were born in the US right
no uncle only you know that's why I have
my birth and your birth certificate says
Pedro Colombia that's all it says only
has my parents in my and the day I was
born - you know I just like a normal
birth certificate you know and you know
I also have my my like life my son
theory - I have his birth certificate
you know and whereas he has me and I so
he was actually born here but he was
born here in between the time we were
moving from Colombia to the United
States right and you said you were AMA
you were from keep though in Colombia
right oh yeah you know you were the
carpet yeah yeah okay all right Pedro
that's obviously not the capital we're
gonna let you go someday we will find
out the truth about Pedro I find him
endlessly entertaining but you know what
what can you do one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get $5 to spend when you
sign up at privacy calm slash Pakman